c'est vital c'est indispensable c'est
une question d'efficacité c'est une
question de revenu fiscal et c'est une
question d'éthique fondamentale nous
allons nous attaquer à ça et je peux
déjà vous donner rendez vous fin mars où
je présenterai que j'eusse commissaire à
la fiscalité ou non la commission
européenne un problème un projet de
taxation pas seulement des gaffes à les
caf à ces quatre compagnies mais le tout
toutes les grandes compagnies du net
celles qui font plus de 750 millions de
chiffre d'affaires
et il ya trois dimensions dans cette
taxation et une dimension mondiale parce
que c'est pas un problème qu'on
rencontre seulement en europe
il faut arriver à identifier ce qu'est
la présence digitale parce que au fond
s'il y échappe à l'impôt c'est parce
qu'on sait plus trop ce qu'ils sont
notre apport sur les choses à faire à
l'intérieur des t-notes impôt sur les
sociétés il a été conçu il ya un siècle
pour des entreprises qui étaient
physiques qui était localisé quelque
part qui en général et et national alors
qu'aujourd'hui sont des entreprises
multinationales
on n'arrive pas à identifier bien les
flux de données on sait pas forcément où
est ce qu'on appelle l'établissement
permanent donc il faut reconstituer à
partir du nombre de clics et partir des
données ip à partir des recettes
publicitaires ce qu'est la présence
digitale
il ya une institution qui s'appelle l'
ocde on travaille là dessus j'ai une
institution mondiale elle va remettre un
rapport en avril déjà le présenter en
mars
il faut vraiment s'appuyer là dessus et
l'union européenne joue le jeu mondial
après une deuxième dimension que les
dimensions européennes
j'ai proposé déjà une grande réforme de
l'impôt sur les sociétés qu'on appelle
l'assiette commune consolidée de l'impôt
sur les sociétés qui consiste simplement
à avoir la même base taxable partout
consolidé au niveau européen ce qui
permet d'éviter les transferts profit ce
tir si vous êtes une entreprise
multinationale babou taxés au centre et
je pense que c'est avec cet outil là en
y intégrant la présence digitale
on peut taxer les géants du net à coeur
enfin une troisième dimension de plus
court terme qui permet de générer des
revenus pour le trésor public qui
consiste à taxer d'une façon ou d'une
autre
l'activité ou le chiffre d'affaires ou
une partie du chiffre d'affaires et je
ferai aussi une proposition dans la
propositions que fera la commission sera
à trois niveaux mondial européenne
structurelles
court terme pour générer des revenus et
je compte vraiment beaucoup sur les
états membres parce que c'est les
responsables